[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Hine we're talking
about basic folk in in this I'm actually
going to take a little sidestep from
book in for just a second because we
have to talk about something that's
really important to understanding sword
work in general and this understanding
is about the timings of the body so
timing is one of the most difficult
things to understand in all martial art
practices a different martial arts have
different ways of talking about timing
and timing is really essential to
everything we're gonna do in the martial
arts
however discussing it logically and
analytically becomes very very difficult
I'm going to use a really simple system
that I discovered this use of the system
from George silver who's a was a
swordsman back in the day in England and
George silver had an interesting method
of talking about this which was the time
of the hand the time of the foot and the
time of the body and that's to
understand that if I'm moving some piece
of me my hand moves the fastest right so
if I need just reach out and grab
something my hand can do it really
really fast my body can do it second
fast so if my hand couldn't move any
further and I had to use my body to
reach over and grab something then that
moves the second-fastest it doesn't move
as fast as my hand but it moves faster
than my foot and so the time of the foot
would be if my hand and Center were
locked in place and actually had to take
a step to grab something somewhere else
this might not seem like it's very
important but understanding this is
pivotal in my opinion a pivotal
understanding a whole lot of Aikido but
sword work particularly and this is not
just the sword work of Aikido it's the
sort of work of of pretty much any
country you want to look into
understanding this concept in one way or
another is really important because
swords are super sharp and so because of
the super sharpness if you're in range
for me to make a quick action with my
hand and I cut you you're almost
certainly gonna get cut now the reason
for this is because you don't have
enough reaction time to deal with my
hands moving into action however if you
can keep it arranged that I can't just
move my hand and attack you that I have
to move my hand with my body to get a
little further reach right so I'll give
you an example here with Josh
okay so talking about that distance
between the two of us right now we're
pretty close to what would be a
fingertip distance right
so this fingertip distance and you know
this is a classic thing and I can't talk
about this all the time in talk about it
so much that people say oh that lame
fingertip distance thing it's really
really important what that fingertip
distance shows us is it's impossible for
me to make any kind of contact with Josh
without moving without taking a step
right so that would mean that's our
longest signing so I can't use the time
of the hand you see way out of range for
that I can't use the time of the buffing
I can we board as far as possible and I
still can't reach Josh I have to use the
time of the foot in order to get to Josh
to make some kind of contact now when
we're talking about sword I'll show you
how we set that was sort but it's the
same basic idea now
if Josh can always keep himself at the
time of the foot and he's worried about
defense he's worried about me making
lightning-fast attacks
he'll probably always have a reaction
time enough of the extra time that he
can get out of the range of that right
so he could probably move his foot every
time right so meaning if I come into
touch Josh right now he can move his
foot out of the way so I'm gonna come in
and get this guy okay you can see I
moved my foot but he had another
reaction time that he can also move his
foot that's great he had max from
reaction time but let's say I'm a little
faster than Josh so if I was a little
bit faster than josh josh could still
generally move his body out of the way
so as I come in he can move that body
out of the way and this is what you see
in prize fighters right when you see
someone coming at him and they're moving
their waist like this to get out of the
way so they're bobbing and weaving to
get out of the way that and that's
because they can still move their body
faster than I can move at that range now
if I was even faster than that when
you're talking about anything room
particularly we talked about sword and
show that in just a second Josh did
still use his hands to defend himself so
here's the type of the hand so if I move
in and still use the time of the hand to
defend himself now that's not ideal
but he can still use that so meaning
that I have could be three magnitudes
faster than Josh and him still possibly
depends what I'm saying this is a lot to
take in so think about this for a second
my foot moves the slowest my body the
second slowest and my hand moves the
fastest so we're in a range that
requires me to take a step always my
slowest time then that means Josh could
have a reaction with this foot it'd be
slower than that he can have a reaction
with his body it'd be slower than that
he can have a reaction with his hands
he's giving himself the best chance to
possibly defend himself against whatever
I'll and now if we were to give our
swords movie magic okay so if we're here
with our swords you can see this is
again analogous to our fingertip
distance so the tips of our swords
touching is the extension of our body
right now in truth this is just a little
bit inside of that range but for most
reasons it will work right so work for
most purposes
meaning it's impossible for me to get
Josh without taking a step right so I
can take my maximum bleeding for my
maximum reach out and can't even reach
his fingers and you could really
probably give up fingers a little bit
because they all have a super they're
protecting his hand so this is analogous
to our fingertip distance which means in
order to get Josh I have to take a step
in if he's about as fast as I am and
able to react quickly what I think is
step in to attack me you can take this
step out let me take a step in not going
to get me anywhere okay even if he's
slower than that so I can take a step
the jobs are so slow he can't take a
step he could move his body out of the
way right so you see still get out of
the way of that Big Shot when I step in
there now more than that is even if I'm
the super fast he can probably get his
hands up there to defendant okay now
that's not what you'd like to do because
these purpose using his sword just for
defense and he's not really setting up a
great attack so if you can who would
like to be able to keep his sword right
on me be
see how much time that affords them when
he does that this is how you're picking
the distancing and sword-fighting is
absolutely critical because the the edge
of a sharp sword will cut you faster
than you can blink right so my hand gets
a few shots to do unless I'm you know
Mike Tyson or something really knocking
this guy out but a sword he can't mess
with so you have to master these
distances these distances are proper my
I are gonna help us in all of Aikido I
know that my eye is not something as
exciting is a coda guys you're a
spinning shyona gay or something really
cool like that but it is fundamental to
understanding Aikido and how we we do
everything in Aikido if you don't
understand my eye then it would be very
difficult to practice the art of Aikido
with swordsmanship my eye which is what
we call it the Japanese word for it is
essential right so in European systems
you call it being in measure and
understand what measure is you have to
understand those distances if you if you
don't understand that then you can't
understand when the critical moment is
for you to be making a strike or
defending against the strike when you're
really in trouble or when you can set
someone up right so I have to be able to
get a good gauge of how fast the other
guy is and then by understanding that I
can I can propria judge my distances so
this is talking about the timings of the
body and my eye specifically for pokken
practice I'm Christopher hi stay tuned